- That, that's the real
answer I mean look,
the most down to earth thing about me
is my parents and my circumstance
creating a framework where I'm
unable to hear the cheering.
Ready? Ready?
This could be a rant in itself.
You may want to...
You'll do what you're going to do.
You're in the zone here, DRock.
Ready?
I'm tired of talking about people
having the ability to
tune out the negative.
I'm done telling you to not worry
about haters and trolls
and negative opinions.
I'm actually flippin' the
fuckin' script on you,
and I'm gonna yell at,
and I'm gonna push at,
and I'm gonna try to
inspire or communicate
a perspective for you to
stop hearing the cheering.
The reason so many
struggle with negativity
is because they overvalue
positive reinforcement.
You're addicted to people
telling you you're pretty.
You're addicted
to people telling you
you're good at basketball.
You're addicted to parents
and teachers telling you
you're a good student.
You're addicted to opinions.
Once you learn how to
not overvalue somebody
who's commending or complimenting you,
is the second you go down the path
of dealing with the reverse.
(downtempo trip-hop)
Could you give me power?
I'm going to film us doing
this on Instagram live.
I think people would enjoy that.
I'm gonna film people, I'm
gonna film us doing this.
- [DRock] So, these are a bunch of clips
and then...
you can just add on your two cents
or title
or however you want to handle it.
- I have an idea of using me up front
and then the clip.
And then title.
Yeah, let's try that.
Or split-screen, I think and then
maybe fade me out,
we haven't done the, that
could be a good idea.
We haven't done a lot of these,
we haven't done on
Instagram where I feed in
and then it goes to the clip.
So maybe we go with the split-screen,
which we know has worked,
and then I fade, like maybe
we get it where I fade out,
and it goes to that.
Wanna do that? Okay cool.
Instagram live, what's up?
Sorry I'm making you go sideways,
but I'm charging my phone
and it wouldn't stand up,
so you go gotta go sideways.
Uh what we're doing now is, I'm
taking you behind the scenes
of how we make the clips for Instagram
where we do a talking over.
So, hope you're well.
I'm salty as fuck.
Fuck football!
- [Jason] I feel like you
had a fire clip yesterday
where you were going off about judgment
and you said, "People would be happier
if you were the only person on the planet"
- Yeah, there was something there.
- [Jason] Do you want to play off that?
- Yeah, I do, good job.
I remember it.
Good job, Jason.
More of that, Jas.
It's the fucking game.
- [Jason] Yeah, it's just
when it catches like, my ear
sometimes we're just in the camera and...
Yeah, and that makes sense to me,
but whether DRock's there-
Well, if DRock's there it's easy.
But he's not,
and even if he is,
it's good muscle memory to like, find it.
It's going to help you in everything.
Your own shit, my shit
and editing, and then
whether there's a way
to do it right then and there, right?
Whether you have your phone
and screenshoot the time
and you go back look at the footage.
Whether, as soon as it's done,
you do your best to try to remember.
Whether it's you're takin'
a shit four hours later
and you're like, "that fuckin' clip."
You write it down or
text it in the thread.
Understand?
The other day, and here's the clip,
and then I'll come right
back and add on top of it.
I really really really think that
it's a much more macro thing,
this comes down to judgment.
If there was nobody else on
Earth, everybody would be happy.
I'm telling you this is a judgment game.
As you can see there, it's
really interesting to me like,
there's some thought that sprung there
which I realize my God, it is literally
and I've been on this
for fuckin' two years,
it is literally the judgment of others
that leads to so much unhappiness and,
and I really genuinely believe
that being the only person on Earth
would lead to so much
happiness for that person.
And you're talking to somebody
desperately loves to socialize
and interact with people um,
but I just absolutely wish
you nothing besides health,
the only thing that I could wish you is
just a deep deep understanding
that other people's opinions
ultimately don't matter,
because they don't have
all the context on you.
How could you value
somebody's opinion of you,
when they don't have the full picture.
How?
And more importantly,
how can you judge someone
when you don't have the full picture.
DRock, look at this post I just posted.
This might be one of the
better things I've wrote.
Look how serious, look
how scary my dad looks.
- [Drock] You're smiling.
- Actually that's good I'm gonna,
actually, in a lot of ways...
- [Drock] What does your dad think of like
when you poke fun at him.
Does he love it?
- He loves it.
Uh, I'd like to start our
next seven or eight hours,
I'd like you have two or
three finalists for me,
maybe, you know, Tyler
you have such a good sense
of where my vibe is so,
something make clearly stand out for you
but if I can get on the
call I'm fine with that.
But I'd like renderings based
on my drawing, uh, ASAP.
Jeff, when you talk to
them about renderings
you gotta show my drawing.
We've got to do a version of that
on the side of the building
if dad says that's a go.
Call him or find him right
now and make sure that's a go.
And then uh, and then
the cup for the main one
and that's gotta be-
You need to take some pictures
and send it over to them,
you know what I mean, Jeff?
(someone presenting loudly on microphone)
- [Jason] Do you get hyped like right now?
- Sometimes,
then other times no.
(echoing microphone)
(audience chanting)
(bells clinking)
This is fact, not opinion
perfect execution,
cause you can waste an
enormous amount of money
on digital.
The amount of people here who've dabbled
and spent three thousand
bucks on Facebook ads
and nothing good has happened, is high.
Right?
Cause the ROI of some things
predicate under skill.
And so, but I can promise you this.
And um, real quick, what is your business?
You have multiple locations one biz, look,
- [Audience Member] One store.
- One human store, right?
Physical store, right?
Where?
- [Audience Member] Hawaii.
- Great.
There is no shot,
that radio and television
can outperform Facebook and Instagram,
if they're both perfectly
executed, here's why.
What Facebook and Instagram let you do,
is have a photo with an
Asian-American family,
and then target Asian-Americans.
With an African-American family,
and then target African-Americans.
With an Ohio State family,
versus a Michigan...
The level of creative
matching who you're reaching,
to create relevance to make
them stop to buy your shit,
is unparalleled.
- [Audience Member] On digital.
- On digital.
As you know, you're not doing
34 different reads on radio.
You got one fuckin' script.
And it's supposed to get to everybody
but it's not relevant.
Not to mention, every day that goes by,
everybody in here's listening to Spotify,
or Apple Music in their
car and not the radio.
So the trends are against consumption,
and then you can't do personalization.
What people don't understand
is I can tell you what to do,
but that's like me telling you,
"Guys! Basketball is a good idea."
I don't know if you've seen
the collective bargaining agreement,
but even average players in the NBA
are now making hundreds
of millions of dollars,
so I think you should
become a basketball player.
That's no different than me telling you
you should do Facebook and Twitter,
you have to be good at it.
But if you own your
business, I don't understand
how you wouldn't take 20 hours
to either read articles on
Google or watch videos on YouTube
to get good at it.
And don't run home and hire
your 24 year old niece,
cause "she's young and she'll get it."
(audience laughing)
This isn't about slipping
into the DM's to hook up,
this is fuckin' business.
- [Drock] One day everyone will
know why this is so amazing
- I can't wait to tell this
story, so the story is,
what DRock's looking at is,
right before I started my live TV in 2006.
I, in December of 2005 decided
that I wanted more innovation
do more new things.
Be on the offense, like
I just talked about.
And I was gonna launch GourmetLibrary.com
cause I was frustrated with Flickr laws
that I couldn't ship everywhere,
which still to this day as
you guys know Wine Text,
Illinois, Texas, so...
I did that, and then I knew
I was gonna build a monster.
And then everybody like oh my God
that was the photo where
I drew out the first site.
However, then I got side tracked
and decided to do a vlog, or a wine show.
On uh, on YouTube, this
new thing that I saw
like a week later.
Uh, or actually I already
knew about YouTube,
and was consuming it.
And um, and that's why.
And now all these years
later, 14 years later, uh,
on the back of Texan.
Which is kind of like the new
retail innovation that I see,
um, I'm gonna launch Yummy Text.
Y-U-M-M-Y text, sign up.
Gourmet foods olive oils,
cheeses, you know, breads.
Uh, jams, chocolates, teas, coffees
at heavily discounted prices
for the highest quality.
It's going to become the thing.
Vlog, super happy that we're
finally kinda getting back into
a regular K this on the
vlog, you know, couple days
back to that daily V.
Which at last maybe far more
contextual in real time uh,
so right now we just found out
Trevor Siemian's out for the year so,
the Jet's are now on
their third quarterback.
Uh, we'll probably put this out before
the game against the Patriots,
I happen to be in Boston, so,
never fun to be in
territory that is enemy.
But, you know it's really funny
this Jet season is turning out to be
very much like my big thesis which is,
there was so much optimism.
You know, we made some
big free agent signings,
we had Sam Darnold year two,
and then between mono
and seven injuries and,
a tough schedule and here we are you know
with the NFL, week two and its like,
it's not looking great.
And so, that's life in business,
that's why I like sports so much like,
you can have everything
organized and planned,
and uh, and be optimistic
and injuries take over.
And so, yeah lets go.
- Huge fan, man.
- Thank you, brother.
- That was awesome.
- Thank you very much.
- That's awesome, real pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- Hope you enjoyed it.
- Yeah, it was awesome.
- Thank you.
Get home safe, take care.
- I'm contemplating.
You know what, we can do
an end of the Key Note
into the summary, and the podcast.
- Yeah, okay, I'll do some stuff.
Podcast, what you're about to see
is probably my most relevant
up to date point of view
on the small business entrepreneur,
state of the union marketing especially
if you're not rolling with
a huge marketing budget.
This is for all the people
that have less than five
thousand dollars to spend
on marketing this year.
Please pay attention, uh,
this is specifically to
the jewelry industry.
Uh, but it resonates with all SMB's.
Podcast peeps I hope you
enjoyed this episode,
I really really appreciate all your love.
Any sharing of the podcast or reviews
on Spotify, Apple, wherever
you're listening to this.
Uh whether it's one star or five star,
your honest point of view of the podcast
would mean a lot to me.
It's the least you could do.
It's a free podcast, fuck!
(hip hop music playing)